the winners and new champions of Dancing  with the Stars are bindi Irwin is our  new Dancing with the Stars champion the  17 year old wildlife conservationist  took home the Mirrorball trophy Tuesday  night following a solid season of high  scores and emotional dances many paying  tribute to her late father Steve Irwin  bindi performed twice during the finale  first recreating this special Viennese  Waltz and later this number as part of  the 24 hour fusion challenge  just as the competition was getting  underway in September  bhindi opened up to ET about honoring  her dad's legacy  I heard the dad would be proud of me  because you know he is he's my superhero  and he always will be and so for us as a  family we've tried so hard to make sure  that everything he loved and lived for  carries on Congrats to the new dancing  champs